good to be out very it's really good
isn't it really good to have an audience
it is wonderful it's
it's so weird adjusting just think
people without masks are the smart
people now
is what it is it's a really weird
adjustment for me
uh yeah it's i don't know what to i
didn't know whether to shake your hands
or not just now
i don't know what to do we're in a weird
moment
we're sort of in between and so i always
have a mask on me and i had put it on
but then other people go like what are
you doing i'm gonna take it off and then
someone else might say put it back on
no it's weird yeah i don't know whose
hand to shake and some people are fist
bumping a dude came up to me uh
on the street and recognized me and i
just found myself motorboating him i
just didn't
[Laughter]
[Music]
i mean but it looks like i mean yes it's
a very strange period but i think we're
going to navigate our way oh yeah but i
i i i'm also filming a show right now
and
and what's weird is hollywood production
has generally not adjusted to
the fact that we are all vaccinated we
are all still wearing our masks
all day as we're filming and it mostly
drives me crazy because i hate it when
republicans are right about
anything and i know that right now if a
republican came to our set was like
you're a bunch of like virtue
signaling hollywood [ __ ] i'd be like
you're right
we are there's no need for these masks
you think it's got yeah because they're
still
blocking people up into zones red zone
blue zone yellow zone it's so
meaningless yeah we're motorboating each
other out here guys
let's take the masks off you can't get a
good motorboat with a mask on
well i beg to disagree
let's try it when i was a surgeon uh
you know i want to thank you because
you were uh you're my first guest on the
tbs
show uh 11 years ago i was and uh very
very nice to do it it's a long time ago
now it was a long time ago yeah
it is a it's a rare distinction in
comedy to be someone's first guest on
their second
talk show actually it was my third that
was your third
talk show yeah even even i'm losing
track
conan's had 45 shows i know i was like
this is the one 38 years
[Laughter]
it was a real honor honestly and i know
you were literally telling me backstage
how you don't like hearing this but i
grew up watching your show
um when i was i think 12 years old when
uh
it first came on so um you know things
like the masturbating bear honestly were
like the things i grew up
uh obsessed with comedically and were
truly like some of my favorite things
and then i got older and i
i got uh to be an actor and i got to be
on the show and i remember the first
time being backstage
and meeting the masturbating bear and
i was like honestly star struck like it
was
it was truly like meeting like tom hanks
or something for the first time
who incidentally also was masturbating
and i saw him yeah
so it was a lot like meeting tom hanks
yeah yeah i mean no i i actually do like
i pretend i kind of don't like it but
i'm very happy when i when
younger comedy people say oh i mean bill
hader
last night was saying he was whatever he
was 15
16. and and would watch it with his
friends and really think this is so
weird and their parents would hate it
but they would like it and i thought oh
that was nice we separated children from
their parents exactly anyway
yes not that i needed that done anyway
it re it reaffirmed the wedge that was
driven between me and my family yeah
um yeah no my mother loves the
masturbating bear oh good
sign of class